hello everyone and welcome to Game four
of the 2018 World Chess Championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and Fabiana
Caruana the result is well the first
three games were drawn so the result is
one and a half each
I wanted half points each and it will be
interesting what for Coulson do what did
the white pieces today how will he look
for his advantage as so far the only
real push for the win we've seen in Game
one where Carlson had the black pieces
so before we check out the actual game
we do have a fairly interesting story
that is kind of going viral on the
internet here we have a tweet by Terry
Swenson he said that he watched a video
by st. Louis chess club this morning of
Caruana doing preparations along ramirez
Dominguez in Sevilla video has now
removed either a huge mistake or an
intentional campaign to misinform team
Carlsen incredible its well basically
they've uploaded a two-minute video on
YouTube regarding some preparation
Caruana sad but in there you you could
easily see some games from chess base
that might indicate on which preparation
and which openings or systems karana is
preparing for so now although this is
very unlikely as I already mentioned on
Twitter you know if an entire episode of
game if an entire season of Game of
Thrones Thrones can be leaked you know
you're accidents do happen but still
even if you see something going on in
there
you know you see an opening you haven't
prepared for a system or something you
might just want to waste a little bit of
more of your time due to that so if it
was a an intentional way to miss inform
Carlson's team you know it's actually
not a bad move but yeah I just wanted to
mention that and we do have a couple of
a couple of nice photos also compliments
of Nikki Riga before we check out the
game here we have a very nice photo and
a very intriguing photo add that here we
have Carson he arrived he shakes Fabiano
caranas hand and it's very interesting
that Carson is standing while Khurana is
sitting down now if I'm sitting down
somewhere and someone you know comes to
my table and he wants to shake my hand I
will usually stand up
it's not doesn't have to be you know
because it's polite or anything it's
simply this just looks weird it's like
it's like a diagonal diagonal handshake
ah okay maybe it's just me I don't know
seems it seems a bit off here and here
we have a very nice photo of Carlson T's
in Corona that he might open with the
Clemens opening a ch3 or perhaps even
the Kaddish opening h4 that is of course
a joke he's only you know most likely
centralizing his pawn as no no the
players will ever make make their force
the first move are usually someone else
will make the first move for them in
this tournament as it has been so far
and sore about that and here we have a
photo of a woman making the first move
for Carlson so I will also use this as a
photo challenge who is the woman and
making the first move for Carlson there
you have it and also here is a very nice
close-up of Magnus the only reason I'm
actually showing this is because it's
well it's just a very nice close-up so
III thought you might enjoy it so there
we have it now that we've seen that
let's check out the actual game like we
already mentioned Carlson has the white
thesis and he opens with not anything to
do with the h1 but rather c4 so the
English opening it had to happen
sometimes as we are in London well they
are and still hoping to see the London
system actually or and a great win win
in the London system you know I actually
wouldn't mind having a video called the
London immortal but okay we have e5
Knight to c3 Knight to f6 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 the four Knights of
reiation of the English we have g3
Michaelson
we have d5 this is a still all standard
C captures on d5 Knight captures on d5
and Bishop to g2 Bishop to c5 a very
nice square for the dark square Bishop
we have castles castles and the b3 so
far this is still also theory and so far
they've been following a game Caruana
already played with the black pieces
against the Wesley so in the grand
Chester a Paris blitz tournament in 2018
so Khurana
Khurana even mentioned
at the press conference that he knows
that he already played this game but he
you know like he says he he forgotten
about it but most likely Carson has it
in his preparations Ruki ate everything
same as was played in that game between
Wesley so and Fabiano core wanna rush up
to d2 we have night captures a bunch of
characters and nights to d4 and this is
a move where we have a new game on our
hands in that Wesley so versus Fabiano
game Wesley continued woodwork to see
one that game was drawn but for this
game across and brings something new to
the board
he plays b4 so what's happening here
obviously the bishop is under attack you
do have to move it somewhere somewhere
yeah we have the Bishop to d6 now
getting it the safety and also giving
more protection to the e5 pawn rook the
b1 and now comes Knight captures on f3
bunch of captures on f3 and here we have
a 6 there was a lot to talk about that
perhaps c6 could also have been played
but then they mentioned that the b5
would be a very nice move for white but
it's actually a very nice idea if you
actually played b5 here then after C
capture some d5 rock after some b5 and
Bishop to h3 attacking the white rook
rook to e1 now you have rook to see a
this is a this is a very cool thing for
black here because although White has
this immense pressure against the b7
pawn you still can't move it because the
rook is stuck on a8 you can actually
play rook to c8 and simply move it
because the bishop on c3 is undefended
so after Queen to a1 defending at Queen
to c7 with a double attack against the
bishop and after the bishop is defended
and now you actually play b6 and
everything is alright here black has
nothing to worry about it would be
actually a very nice position for black
but ok you don't have to push b6
immediately after c6 is played but also
I thought it'd be a nice theme to show
you maybe you will be able to use this
if you will have a similar situation
where your light square bishop is still
undeveloped and your Luke is stuck on a8
so perhaps in your own games white will
have a bishop on c3 that you can use to
get a tempo
with the rook a burka Asics was played
in this game with a for Michaelson and
now comes c6 and here cross and preceded
preceded with rook to e1 and again there
was a lot of talk about what if b5 is
actually played here and after eight
captures pawn captures Bishop to d7 now
you this blogger I mentioned this a few
times then let's say after a pawn
captures on c6 Bishop captures and c6
Bishop captures pawn captures even
though our black's pawn structure is
somewhat weakened there is an isolated
pawn and c6 unit was a convinced that
black wouldn't have any problems here
after the Queen defends the pond with
Queen d7 that's the rook can even use
this to go look to e6 and perhaps a rope
to rope to h6 or perhaps the route can
go somewhere else along the 6th rank and
even black and starts an attack with h5
and H 4 but unit is a very aggressive
player so no doubt she would find some
attacking ideas here but ok after c6
cross and does not go for the immediate
b5 he plays rook to e1 and brush-up to
d7 now enforcing the b v square we have
III by Carlson and Queen to f6 now we
have Bishop to g4 now this is a very
very very nice central square for the
Bishop Caruana just by Queen to f6 so it
is no longer to get this pawn to f5 also
you didn't mentioned here that that a
very nice move here might be just moving
the Queen back Queen to e6 and then
preparing at 5 but still it's hard hard
to decide how to do this if white goes
Queen to h5 goes after the h7 phone now
f5 Bishop goes back to g2 or h1 well or
h1 or
g2 then Queen can come back to f6 but
the problem is although it is a very
nice position for black how will how
will black take advantage of this so so
far he's a bishop error seems to be
doing pretty much nothing and it will be
hard for for black to break through
White's King side here as there's a
really no good square for the Queen here
if you want to keep the
Queens on the board here the queen is
occupying the same squares rook anyone
if you put the Queen on f6 or something
like this then you will also get
something like f4 as the bishop and c3
would make it impossible for black to
actually capture here and also I thought
about an interesting move Queen to a -
I'm going after the e4 pawn and perhaps
using this as a momentum to push up for
at some point now but it would be very
hard if white simply defense a5 now you
will not be able to push up for simply
because Bishop to e4 will be will be too
devastating now after g6
I will simply be able to give up the
bishop as your dark square bishop for
example is undefended on d6 can move
screen captures and the white will be
winning here but yeah surely an
interesting idea where a lot of moves
different can be played differently for
black but here Bishop to f5 Fabiano
decided to offer a trade of bishops
would have Queen to f3 basically
offering a queen trade and Fabiano
accepts it will push up captures on e4
Queen captures on f6 and in between move
pawn captures pawn captures and now
finally b5 by Carlson we have roped a
b-1 Bishop back to f8 we have pawn
captures on b5 pawn captures on b5 and
now King to g2 across and starts
improving the position of his King we
have rook e to d8 and now comes look D
to C 1 as black has a weak backwards e6
pawn Carlsen will definitely enjoy
taking advantage of this we have a king
to g7 also black wants to improve the
position of asking maybe even come to g6
at some point but should be back to e1
white will always have to keep his dark
square Bishop here he won't he will have
to defend this before pawn as black will
at some point attack at VI rook to a4 we
have rook need to c8 defending the pawn
but also hoping to maybe push c5 at some
point and get rid of his weak backwards
pawn but when you push this pawn then
this point becomes a week so there's
really no way to ever do it
look the situ and here we have rook to a
for now the B for point is attacked
twice and also it's attacked what it's
attack twice and defended twice we have
King to f3 by Carson and here h5 not
allowing the Carson to perhaps take this
perhaps moments to go King g4 to f5 f5
would be a very nice work for the King
but it's not I mean there's no move you
can imagine black making that would
allow this trip for the waiking but even
if we do this let's say you know just
just for just for laughs that black
would actually play Bishop to e7 King
goes here black plays Bishop back to a
faith King goes here there's not all
that much the King can do here for
example if h5 is played now then the
White King really has nowhere to go
it's like stuck on f5 so ok I don't have
a light square bishop or Knight to do
anything about this but you know perhaps
it would be very uncomfortable
oh ok after King to f3 we have h5
Khurana doesn't even allow Carson to
think about this we have King to eat you
and now comes King to g6 that perhaps
preparing to push f5 at some point but
Carson also know that the King has moved
from f3 will be thinking about pushing
f4 at some point we have h3 and now
comes f5 pawn captures on f5 15 captures
on effort and now f3 so a very nice
shield here against the black King and
now comes Bishop to e7 we have E 4 with
check King moves to e6 and now comes
Bishop - D - we have Bishop to d6 now
preventing white from ever executing f4
and here Baroque b2 c1 was played and it
was actually in this position unmoved 34
that the players agree to a draw it was
actually Magnus Carlsen who offered the
draw there's a I mean the the engine's
evaluation is that you know it's it was
a good call that's there's perhaps for
for general viewers it would be nice to
play it out all the way to the end
because Carson has announced in the
opening ceremony of the 2018 Watchers
Championship match that he will push
every game up until the end but to
twenty-eight hundred plus players this
makes a very little sense because the
CSEC spawn is attacked twice if you
defend it with the king then comes rook
831 you can also defend the b-pawn with
rook to be one but rook to d1 is also a
very nice active defense now that the
King is occupying the same file as the
rook and you will not be able to capture
anything with the bishop as this would
be a very nice discovered check so after
King b7 white will simply move the rule
back attack the c6 pawn and on the other
hand after Ruby to c1
if you play something like Bishop capped
or some before then you can go into this
force variation capture some before rook
captures and look at verse and c6 would
check rook captures rook captures and
after the King moves and now comes rook
to h6 attacking the h5 pawn and it seems
why white is perhaps making some
progress here but look to be to check
and now after the King moves rook to b3
check will force the White King back as
if the White King allows it then black
is actually the one that will be
gobbling up all the pawns on the King
side so white will just have to move
back and forth and again we will have a
drawing sequence so after look b2 c1 the
players like we said agree to a draw
unmoved 34 so it's not unmoor 30 I don't
know if any of you know this but if if
at least 30 moves have not been played
they're not allowed to to agree to a
draw so at least 30 moves have have to
be played before they can agree to a
draw so for games played we still have
eight more to go in the classical time
format then we are entering rapid games
if also that will be drawn then blitz
games and then in the end I believe I
haven't checked but I believe there is
of course an Armageddon game so yeah now
I would also like to mention there have
been a couple of funny moments in the
press conference after this game as the
president of the Jamaican Chess
Federation mark Holmes he has two
Fabiano if the in Game five he will play
perhaps something different than a four
that it seems that Magnus already has
gotten quite used to e4 and that he's
perhaps getting too comfortable which I
mean it was
really funny since obviously Khurana
will not mention what he will play in
the next game you know in front of
everyone and especially in front of
Magnus as that would only ease his
preparation and also he mentioned that
you know this is too much draws I want
to see blood sweat and tears and that is
basically the reason why this video is
called blood sweat and tears so yeah
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Yaakov
Petula David Compton William Bret banner
Daniel Whitehead and a William Avery for
a contribution to my channel I think you
oughta really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content and of course do
share how are you enjoying the World
Chess Championship 2018 so far thank you
all and I'll see you soon